we're in the meat in
greet this woman in a wheelchair gives
him acid she was like hey I'll trade you
some acid for a T-shirt and I was like
deal and do you have the acid she goes
no you didn't have any t-shirts yeah
they were your t-shirts no you yeah I
didn't lose any money I made a profit of
10 hits like so she said I'll come back
after the late show and we'll do a trade
I was like great so she comes back and
we do a little Switcheroo and it wasn't
just like one hit of acid it was like 10
hits of acid I was likeing yeah like
that's awesome you don't take drugs from
someone in the meet and greets but it
wasn't at the meet and greet it was
after the meet and greet the after show
how do you know that the acid didn't put
her in the
wheelchair hey I'm going to tell you
right now that sounds like some pretty
good assd that's and and I will tell you
I will tell you the acid she gave me is
some of the most fun I've ever had on
acid